The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right,
welcome to my last lecture
for the semester.
We finish our coverage
of dynamic graphs,
and also our coverage
of lower bounds.
We saw one big lower
bound in this class
in the cell probe model.
You may recall cell
probe model, you just
count how many cells
of memory do you touch.
You want to prove a
lower bound on that.
And today we're going to prove
a cell probe from lower bound
on dynamic connectivity,
which is a problem we've
solved a few different times.
Our lower bound
will apply even when
each of the connected components
of your graph are just a path.
And so in particular, they
imply matching lower bounds
for dynamic trees.
So here is the theorem
we'll be proving today.
You want to insert
and delete edges,
and do connectivity queries
between pairs of vertices, vw.
I want to know is there
a path from v to w,
just like we've
been considering.
These require omega log
n, time for operation.
This is the max of
updating, query times has
to be at least log n
time per operation,
even if the connected
components are paths, and even
amortized, and even randomized.
Although I'm not going to
prove of all of these versions,
I won't prove the
amortized version.
I'm going to prove a worst
case log and lower bound,
it's just a little more work to
prove an amortized lower bound.
But same principles.
And so that's going to be
today, is proving this theorem.
It's not a short
proof, but it combines
a bunch of relatively
simple ideas,
and ends up being pretty
clean overall, piece-by-piece,
but there's just a bunch of
pieces, as we will get to.
Key concept is an
idea introduced
in this paper, which is
to build a balanced binary
tree over time, over
your access sequence.
And argue about different
subtrees within that tree.
This is a paper that maybe
came out of this class,
in some sense, it was by
Mihai Patrascu and myself.
Back when Mihai
was an undergrad,
I think he'd just
taken this class.
But at that point
the class didn't even
cover dynamic connectivity, so--
and time here is cell probes.
So this is a very
strong model, it
implies a lower bound on ram,
and implies a lower bound
on pointer machine.
We know matching
upper bounds for trees
on a pointer machine
link/cut trees
in [INAUDIBLE] to our trees.
It's kind of fun that this lower
bound even applies to paths,
because most of the
work in link/cut trees
is about decomposing
your tree into paths.
And so what this is saying is
even if that's done for you,
and you just need to be able
to take paths, and concatenate
them together by adding edges,
then maintaining the find root
property so that you can
do connectivity queries,
even that requires log n time.
So converting a tree into
a path is basically free,
the hard part is
maintaining the paths.
So let's prove a theorem.
The lower bound,
we get to choose
what access sequence
we think is bad.
And so we're going to come
up with a particular style
of graph, which looks
like the following.
Graph is going to be--
the vertices are going to
be a root n by root n grid.
And we're going to--
these guys are in,
what did I call them?
Groups?
Columns.
Columns is a good name.
These are columns of
the matrix, or vertices.
And what I'd like to have is
between consecutive columns,
I want to have a
perfect matching
between these vertices.
So could be, I don't know, this
edge, this edge, this edge,
and that edge.
And I also want a perfect match
between these two columns,
so maybe this one, this
one, this one, this one.
And you can have some
boring things too.
Something like that.
So between every pair of
columns is a perfect matching,
meaning perfect pairing.
OK, this of course results
in a collection of paths,
square root of n paths.
You can start at any
vertex on the left,
and you'll have a unique
way to go to the right.
And so that's path 1, this
is path 2, this is path 3,
and this is path 4.
And so if I-- an
interesting query.
Well, an interesting query is
something like I want to know,
is this vertex
connected to this one?
And it's not so easy
to figure it out,
because you have to sort
of walk through this path
to figure that out.
We're going to think of each
of these perfect matchings
as defining a permutation on the
vertices, on the column really.
So you start with the
identity permutation,
and then some things get
swapped around, that's pi 1.
Something gets swapped
around again, that's pi 2.
Somethings get swapped
around here, that's pi 3.
And then this position would
be pi 3 of pi 2 of pi 1
of vertex 4.
We call this vertex 4.
Or row, row 4.
So in some sense, we have
to compose permutations.
I'll call this pi 1, circle
pi 2, circle pi 3 of 4.
And we're going to
show, basically,
composing permutations is
tough when you can change
those permutations dynamically.
So what we're going
to do is a series
of block operations,
which change or query
entire permutations.
So here, an update is going to
be a whole bunch of insertions
and deletions of edges.
Basically, what we want to
do is set pi i equal to pi.
So that's what update
of i comma pi does.
It changes an entire
perfect matching
to be a specified permutation.
So how do you do that?
Well, you delete
all the edges that
are in the existing
permutation, then
you insert all the new edges.
So this can be done in square
root of n edge deletions
and insertions.
So it's a bulk update of
square root of n operations.
And so this could only
make our problem easier,
because we're given
square root of n updates
that we all need to do at once.
So you could amortize
over them, you
could do lots of
different things,
but we're sure that won't help.
And then we have a
query, and the query
is going to be a
little bit weird,
and it's also going to make
the proof a little bit more
awkward.
But what it asks is if I look at
the composition of pi j, from 1
up to i.
This is 1.
So I want to know is that
composition equal to pi?
Yes or no?
This is what I'll call verify
sum, sum meaning composition.
But the sum terminology comes
from a different problem,
which we won't
talk about directly
here, called partial sums.
Partial sums is
basically this problem,
you can change
numbers in an array,
and you can compute the
prefix sum from 1 up to i.
Here we're not computing it.
Why are we not computing it?
Because actually figuring out
what pi 3, or pi 2 of pi 1
is of something is
tricky in this setting.
The operations we're given
are, given two vertices,
are they connected by a path?
So to figure out the other end
of this path, that requires--
I mean, it's hard to figure
out where the other end is.
If I told you is it this one?
Then I can answer that question
with just a connectivity query.
So verify sum can be done
with order square root
of n connectivity queries.
Whereas computing the sum could
not be, as far as we know.
If I tell you what that
composition is supposed to be,
I can check does 4 go to 1?
Yes or no?
Does 3 go to 3?
Does 2 go to 4?
Yes or no?
Does 1 go to 2?
So with 4 queries, I can
check whether the permutation
is what it is.
If any of those fail,
then I return no.
So the way this proceeds is
first we proved a lower bound
on partial sums,
which is computing
this value when you're not
told what the answer is.
And then we extended that,
and we'll do such a proof here
today.
First, we're going to prove
a lower bound on the sum
operation, which is
computing this value that's
on our outline over
here, sum lower bound.
And then we'll extend that and
make the argument a little bit
more complicated, then we'll
get an actual connectivity lower
bound, a lower
bound on verify sum.
OK, but obviously
if we can prove
that these operations
take a long time to do,
we can prove that these original
operations take a long time
to do.
So what we claim is that
square root of n updates,
these block updates plus square
of n verify some queries,
require root n times
root n log n cell probes.
I guess this is the
amortized claim.
So if I want to do root n
updates and root n queries,
and I take root n times
root n times log n--
funny way of writing n log n--
cell probes, then
if I divide through,
I want the amortized
lower bound,
I lose one of these
root ns, because I'm
doing different operations.
I lose another root n,
because each of these updates
corresponds to
root n operations.
Each of the verify
sums corresponds
to root n operations.
So overall per operation,
per original operation
of edge deletion insertion
or connectivity query,
I'm paying log n per operation.
So if I can prove this claim,
then I get this theorem.
All clear?
So now we've reduced the problem
to these bulk operations,
we'll just be thinking
about the bulk operations,
update verify sum.
We won't think about
edge deletion insertions
and connectivity
queries anymore.
OK.
So this is just sort
of the general set up
of what the graphs are
going to look like.
And now I'm going to tell
you what sequence of updates
and verify sums we're actually
going to do that are bad.
This is the bad access sequence.
And this is actually something
we've seen before in lecture 6,
I think, the binary
search tree stuff.
We're going to look at
the bit reversal sequence.
So you may recall a
bit reversal sequence.
You take binary numbers in
order, reverse the bits.
So this becomes 000, 100, 010,
110, 001, 101, 011, and 111.
So those are the
reversed strings.
And then you reinterpret
those as regular numbers.
So this is 0, 4,
2, 6, and then it
should be the same thing,
but the odd version.
So I have 1, 5, 3, 7.
OK, I claimed, I think
probably didn't prove,
that this bit reversal sequence
has a high Wilber lower bound.
And so any binary search tree
accessing items in this order
requires log n per operation.
And we want log n
per operation here,
so it seems like a
good choice, why not?
So we're going to follow
this access sequence.
And sorry, I've
changed notation here,
we're going to number
the permutations from 0
to root n minus 1 now.
And assume root n
is a power of 2,
so the bit reversal
sequence is well defined.
And then we are going to do
two things for each such i.
We're going to do a
verify sum operation.
Actually maybe it is
starting at 1, I don't know.
It doesn't matter.
And then we'll do an update
OK, so let's see.
This pi random is just a
uniform random permutation,
it's computed fresh every time.
So we're just re-randomizing
pi i in this operation.
Before we do that,
we're checking
that the sum, the composition
of all the permutations up
to position i, is what it is.
So this is the
actual value here,
and we're verifying that
that is indeed the sum.
So this will always return yes.
But data structure
has to be correct.
So it needs to really verify
that that is the case.
There's the threat that maybe
we gave the wrong answer here,
and it needs to double
check that that is indeed
the right answer.
It may seem a little weird,
but we'll see why it works.
So this is the bad
access sequence.
Just do a query, do an update
in this weird order in i.
OK, and big idea is to
build a nice balanced binary
tree over time.
So we have on the ground
here 0, 4, 2, 6, 1, 5, 3, 7.
And when I write 5, I
mean verify sum of 5,
and update permutation 5.
And then we can build
a binary tree on that.
And for each node
in this tree, we
have the notion
of a left subtree,
and we have the notion
of a right subtree.
And cool thing about
bit reversal sequence
is this nice self-similarity.
If you look at the left
subtree of any node
and the right subtree of any of
node, those items interleave.
If you look at the sorted
order, it's 1 on the left,
3 on the right, 5 on the
left, 7 on the right.
They always
perfectly interleave,
because this thing is
designed to interleave
at every possible level.
So that's the fact
we're going to use.
We're going to analyze each node
separately, and talk about what
information has to be
carried from the left subtree
to the right subtree.
In particular, we're
interested in the updates being
done on the left subtree,
because here we change pi 1,
we change pi 5.
And the query's being
done on the right subtree,
because here we
query 3, we query 7.
When we query 3, that
queries everything,
all the permutations, up to 3.
It's a composition of
all permutations up to 3.
So in particular it involves 1.
So the claim is going to be
that the permutation that we
set in 1 has to be carried
over to this query.
And similarly, a
changing permutation 5
will affect the query for 7.
Also query, the update for 1,
So we need to formalize
that little bit.
So here is the claim.
For every node in
the tree, say it
has l leaves in its subtree--
This should be a comma and
this should be a colon.
Here's what we say.
During the right subtree
of v, so right subtree
corresponds to an
interval of time.
So we're talking about
those operations done
during the right subtree
of v. Claim is we must
do omega l root n cell probes--
sorry, expected cell probes.
We are using some
randomness here, right?
We said we're going to
update each permutation
to a random value,
so we can only
make claims about the
expected performance.
Fine.
But that's actually
a stronger thing,
it implies a lower bound, even
for randomized algorithms.
So if you can randomize
your input set.
And then not just
any cell probes,
but they're cell probes
that read cells last written
during the left subtree.
So this is what I was saying
at a high level before.
We're looking at
reads over here,
to cells that are
written over here.
Because we claim the
updates over here
have to store some
information that is--
whatever the updates that happen
over here influence the queries
that happen over here.
So these queries have
to read the data that
was written over here.
And specifically, we're
claiming at least l root n
cell probes have to
be read over here,
from cells that were written--
that were basically just
written in the left subtree.
If we could prove this, then
we get our other claim--
this one over here, that root
n updates, and root n verifies
sums that require
this much time.
The difference
is-- well, here we
have an l, for an l leaf tree.
And so what I'd like to
do is sum this lower bound
over every node in the tree.
I need to check that
that is valid to do.
So let's do that.
OK, for every node
v, we are claiming
there's a certain number of
reads that happen over here,
that correspond to
writes over here.
But let's say you
look at the parent
of v, which is over here.
This thing is also
in the right subtree,
and we're claiming there's
some number of reads
on the right subtree, that read
things that are written over
on the left.
The worry would be that
the reads we counted here,
we also count at
the next level up.
We don't want to double
count in our lower bounds.
If we're able to sum them up,
we can't be double counting.
But the claim is
we're not double
counting, because if you
look at any particular--
any read-- so here's time, and
suppose you do a read here.
You're reading a cell that was
written sometime in the past,
if it was never written, it's
a not very interesting read,
it communicates no information.
So there's some write
in the past that changed
the cell that's just read.
And we are going
to count this read
at a particular node, namely
the lca of those two times.
So if you look at
the lca of the times
of the reads and the writes,
that is the single note
that we'll think
about that read that
happened in the right
subtree, that was
written in the left subtree.
So no double counting, because
we only count at the lca.
The other thing that we
need to be able to do
is, because this is an
expected lower bound,
we need linearity
of expectation.
But expectation is indeed
linear, so we're all set.
OK, so all that's left
is a little bit of common
[INAUDIBLE] if we take l
root n, where l is the size
of the subtree
below a given node,
we sum that up over all nodes,
and it's a balanced binary
search tree--
or a balanced binary tree, I
should say, not a search tree.
What do we get?
Well, every leaf appears
in log n subtrees.
So we get the total size of
the tree times log n for this,
and we get another
root n over here.
The total size of
the tree is root n.
So we get this root
n log n, that's
when you sum up the l part.
Then everything gets
multiplied by root n,
and that becomes
our lower bound,
and that's exactly
what we need over here.
So now this claim is done.
Maybe I should do a check mark.
Provided we can
prove this claim.
So now our goal is
to prove this thing.
And now we're in a
more local world,
looking at a single node,
counting reads over here,
the corresponding
rights over there.
And then you just add
up those lower bounds,
you get what you want.
So this is where
the log comes from,
because it's a balanced tree.
And there's log n levels in
a balanced tree, that's where
we're getting our lower bound.
The root n's are just keeping
track of the size of the things
we're manipulating.
All right.
So it remains to
prove this claim.
Prove that claim,
we get that claim,
and then we get this theorem.
So proof of claim.
We're going to do an
information theoretic
argument, so let me set it up.
It's again, it's
making this claim
I said before, that
the permutations that
get written over
here somehow have
to be communicated to
the queries over here,
because they matter.
Because the permutations
that get said over here
changed the answers to
all the queries over here,
because of the interleaving
between left and right.
So how are we going
to formalize that?
Well, left subtree
does l/2 updates
with l/2 random permutations,
uniform random permutations,
because every node
does an update.
And so the information
theoretic idea
is that if we were to somehow
encode those permutations,
That encoding must
use omega l log l--
l?
No, I'm sorry.
It's not right.
Off by some root n factors
here, l root n log n.
OK, each permutation
must take root n
log root n bits to encode.
If you have a
random permutation,
expected number of bits have
a very high probability.
Almost every
permutation requires
root n log root n bits.
I'm not going to worry
about constant factors,
put an omega here, so the
root n turns into an n.
And then we've got
l over two of them,
so again, ignoring constant
factors, that's l root n log n
bits.
And this is just
information, theoretic fact,
our common [INAUDIBLE]
theory fact.
And once we know that,
the idea is let's
find an encoding that's
better than this,
and get a contradiction.
Of course we shouldn't
get a contradiction
unless this claim is false.
So either this claim is
true and we're happy,
but if somehow the
word not enough cell
reads on the right, that
did things that were written
on the left, then
we will, from that,
get a smaller encoding of
the update permutations
that happen on the left.
If we could somehow
do that, then we
can get a contradiction, and
therefore conclude the claim
is in fact true.
So, if the claim fails, we'll
find a smaller encoding, which
will give us a contradiction.
All right, so let's set up
this problem a little bit more.
I'm going to--
because we're really
just interested in this subtree
v stuff on the left, stuff
on the right, but this of course
lives in a much bigger tree,
there's stuff that
happens over here.
This I will call the past.
I'm just going to assume we
know everything about the past.
Everything to the
left of the subtree,
we can assume that we know.
When I say we know,
what do we know?
We know all the updates, we know
all the queries that happen,
and we know, at this
moment in particular,
what is the state of
the data structure.
Because this claim has
nothing to do with this stuff,
it's all about reads here that
corresponds to writes here.
So we can just assume we know
everything up to this point.
In our encoding,
this is a key point.
One way to say this in
a probabilistic sense
is we're conditioning on
what happened over here
on the left, what
updates happened.
And if we can prove that
whatever we need to happen here
holds no matter what
the condition is,
then it will hold overall.
So that's probabilistic
justification
for why we can assume
we know the past OK.
So then our goal
is to encode, this
is a little bit
different from this goal.
What we really want to do is
encode the update permutations
on the left.
That's a little
awkward to think about,
because this is a claim
about how many probes
happen on the right.
So instead, what
we're going to do
is encode the query
permutations on the right.
So there are updates over here,
that's what we want to encode,
but we're instead going to
encode the queries over here.
I claim if you know what
the results of the queries
were over here,
then you know what
the updates were over there.
Basically because of this
interleaving property.
So I can write that down
a little more formally.
So if we look at
time here, over,
let's say this is v's subtree.
Then what we have are
a sequence of updates
and a sequence of queries.
These are queries,
and these are updates.
This is what the
sequence looks like--
sorry, this is v's subtree,
this is the pi is, I should say.
I mean, these operations are
all happened during time,
but now I'm sorting by i.
A little confusing.
There are two orders
to think about, right?
There's the sequence
over time, we're
now looking at
such a left subtree
where we do say 1, 5, and 3, 7.
What that means-- so you're
imagining here, this is 1,
this is 5, this is 3, this is 7.
Here we're sorted by the
value written down there,
we're sorting by the i,
the pi i that they're
changing or querying.
And so all the read things
are in the right subtree of v.
And all the updates are
in the left subtree of v.
This is the
interleaving property
that I mentioned earlier.
So I claim that if I encode
the results of the queries,
namely I encode
these permutations,
these are like summary--
partial sums.
These are prefixed sums
of the permutation list.
Then I can figure out
what the updates were.
Why?
Because if I figure out
what this query, what
it's permutation
is, that's the sum
of all of these permutations.
Now only one of them
changed in the left subtree,
the rest all are in the past.
They were all set before
this time over here,
and I know everything about
the past, I'm assuming.
So most of these I already
know, the one thing I don't know
is this one, but I claim
if I know this sum,
and I know all the others,
then I can figure out
what this one is, right?
It's slightly awkward to
do, if I give you this,
I give you the sum of pi j from
j equals 0 to i, or something.
I've got to--
I want to strip away all
these, strip away all these.
So I'm going to multiply by
sum of pi j inverses over here,
and multiply by sum pi j--
when I say multiply,
I mean compose.
Sum pi j inverse is
here, maybe let's not
worry about the
exact indices here.
But the point is, this
is all in the past,
and this is all in the past,
so I know all these pi js,
I know they're inverses.
So if I have this
total sum, and I right
multiply with these
inverses, left
multiply with these inverses,
I get the one that I want.
This gives me some particular pi
k, if I set the indices right.
OK?
So if I know this query, I
figure out what this update is.
Now once I know what this update
is, and I know this query, then
in this sum, I know everything
except this one thing.
And so by using
the same trick, I
can figure out what
this update is.
So now I know the
first two updates,
if I then know the
answer to this query,
I can figure out
what this update is.
If I know the answer
to this query,
I can figure this update.
Because they're
perfectly interleaved,
I only need to reconstruct
one update at a time.
So if I'm given--
if I've somehow encoded
all of the queries results,
all of these prefix sums,
and I'm given the past,
then I can reconstruct
what all the updates were.
So that's basically saying
these two are the same issue.
If I can encode the verified
sums in the right subtree,
using less than l
root n log n bits,
then I'll get a contradiction,
because it implies
that from that
same encoding, you
can also decode the
update permutations
in the left subtree.
So that's our goal.
OK.
So we'd like to prove
this for verify sum.
But the first thing
I'm going to do
is consider an easier
problem, which is sum.
So suppose, basically, this
was not an input to the query.
Suppose the query was,
what is the sum of i?
Like this.
I just want-- this is
the partial sum problem.
I'm given an index
i, I want to know
what is the permutation
from pi 0 up to pi i.
Now that is not--
that doesn't correspond
to dynamic connectivity,
it's a new problem.
We'll first prove a lower
bound for that problem,
and then we'll put the
verify word back in.
OK, so that's-- we're now
here at sum lower bound.
Where should I go?
Different-- so this is a lower
bound on the operation sum,
as opposed to here, where
we're adding up lower bounds.
Sorry for the
conflation of terms.
Let's go here.
So I'll call this a warm up.
Suppose a query
is sum of i, which
is supposed to give you this
prefix sum of pi j again,
sum means composition.
So this is going to be
relatively easy to prove,
but it's not the problem
we actually want to solve,
we'll use it to then
solve the real problem.
And this is the order in which
we actually solve things.
First, we prove a lower
bound of partial sums.
OK, so let me give
you some notation,
so we can really
get at this claim.
Reading on the right,
writing on the left.
So let r be all
the cells that are
read during the right subtree,
which is an interval of time.
And let w be the cells
written in the left subtree.
OK, so what we're
talking about over here
is that r intersects
w, those are cells that
are read during the
right subtree, that
were at some point written
during the left subtree,
should be large.
So we want to
prove a lower bound
on the size of r intersect w.
So if the lower
bound doesn't hold,
that means that r intersect
w is relatively small.
So imagine a situation where
r intersect w is very small,
there's not very
much information
passed from the left subtree
to the right subtree.
If r intersect w is
small, then presumably I
can afford to write it
down, I can encode it.
So that's what we're going
to do, and we'll compute--
we'll figure out that this is
indeed something we can afford.
I'm going to encode r
intersect w explicitly.
Meaning-- and this is a
set of cells in memory.
So for every cell, I'm
going to write down
what it's address is, and what
the contents of the cell are.
So write down the
addresses and the contents
for every such cell.
So how many bits does that take?
I'm going to say that it's r
intersect w times log n bits.
Here's where I need to
mention an assumption.
I'm assuming that the address
space is order log n bits long,
that's like saying that the
space of your data structure
is order--
is polynomial in n.
And if you want any hope of
having a reasonable update
time, you need to have
polynomial space at most.
So assuming polynomial space,
each of those addresses only
takes order log n
bits to write down.
The contents, let's say,
also take order log n bits
to write down.
OK, so fine.
That's-- I mean, yeah.
We don't really need to
make those assumptions,
I don't think, but we will for
here to keep things simple.
So if r intersect w is
small, meaning smaller
than this thing, then this will
be small, smaller than l root
log n.
OK.
So on the other hand, we know
that every encoding should
take l root n log n bits.
And so this will
be a contradiction,
although we haven't quite
encoded what we need yet,
or we haven't proved
that, but we're getting
to be at the right point.
These log ns are going
to cancel in a moment.
So what we need to do is,
I claim this is actually
enough to encode what we need.
And so all that's left is a
decoding algorithm for the sum
queries in the right subtree.
So how are we going to do that?
So this is my encoding,
these are the bits
that I have written down.
So now what I
know, as a decoder,
is I know everything
about the past.
I don't know what
these updates are,
that's my whole goal, to
figure out what they are.
I don't know what the
results of the queries
are, but magically, I
know that r intersect w.
Well, not magically.
I wrote it down, kept
track on a piece of paper.
So that's what I know.
And so the idea
is, well, somebody
gave us a data structure,
tells you how to do an update,
tells you how to do a query.
Let's run the query
algorithms over here.
Run that query, run
that query, or whatever.
It's a little hard to
run them, because we
don't know what happened
in this intermediate part.
But I claim r intersect w tells
us everything we need to know.
So the decoding algorithm is
just simulate sum queries,
simulate that algorithm.
And let's go up here.
How do we simulate
that algorithm?
Well, the algorithm
makes a series of cell
reads, and maybe writes, but
really we care about the reads.
Writes are pretty
easy to simulate.
There are three cases for reads.
It could be that the thing
you're trying to read
was written in
the right subtree,
it could be that it was
written in the left subtree,
or it could be it was
written in the past,
before we got to v subtree.
Now we don't necessarily
know which case we're in,
but I claim we'll be
able to figure it out.
Because any cells that are
written in the right subtree,
we've just been running
the simulation algorithm,
so every time we do
it right, we just
can store it off to the side.
So when we're doing
simulations, we
don't need that the
simulation takes low space.
We just need that the input--
these decoding algorithms
doesn't have to be
low space, we just
need that the
encoding was small.
We've already made
the encoding small.
And so the decoding
algorithm can
spend lots of time
and space, we just
need to show that decoding
algorithm can recover
what it's supposed to recover.
It's like a
compression algorithm,
to show there's some
way to decompress,
could take arbitrarily
amount of time and space.
So when we're simulating
the right subtree,
and we simulate not only the sum
queries, but also the updates.
So whatever gets written
during that simulation,
we just store it, and so
it's easy to reread it.
If it was written
in the left subtree,
well, that is r intersect w.
And we've written
down r intersect w.
So we can detect
that this happened,
because we look
at r intersect w,
we see, oh that
word was in there,
that address was
in there, and so
we read the contents
from the encoding.
If it was in the
past, it's also easy.
We already know it.
OK, so basically what we do--
what the simulation algorithm
is doing is it says,
OK, let's assume
that main memory was
whatever it was at this point.
That data structure, I mean we
know everything about the past,
so we know what the
data structure looked
like at this moment, store that.
Update all of the cells
that are in r intersect
w given by our encoding.
And then just run the algorithm.
So we're sort of jumping
into this moment in time
with a slightly
weird data structure.
It's not the correct
data structure.
It's not what the data
structure will actually
look like at this point,
but it's close enough.
Because anything
that's read here,
either was written
here, in which case
it's correct, or was
written here, in which case
it's correct because
r intersect w had it.
Or isn't it written
here, in which case--
maybe it's always correct.
No, no.
See there could be
some writes that
happened here, where there's no
corresponding read over here.
So the data structure may
have been changed in ways here
that don't matter for this
execution of the right subtree.
So any rights that happened
here to some cell probe,
to some cell, where that
cell is not read over here,
we don't care
about, because they
don't affect the simulation.
So we have a good
enough data structure
here, it may not be
completely accurate,
but it's accurate enough
to run these queries.
Once we run the queries,
the queries output the sums.
That's what we're assuming in
this warm up, we run the query,
we get the sum.
Once I have that sum,
as I argued before,
once you know what the
results of these queries were,
I can figure out what the
arguments to the updates were,
by doing that inverse
multiplication stuff.
So that's actually it.
What this implies is that this
is a correct encoding, which
means that this order,
r intersect w times log
n bits that we use to encode,
must be at least this big.
Because we know any
encoding is going
to require at least that
many bits, l root n log n.
And so the log ns
cancel, and we're
left with r intersect
w is at least l root n.
And this is exactly the quantity
we cared about for this claim.
So same thing, r intersect
w is at least l root n.
OK, so warm up done.
Any questions about the warm up?
So in this weird
problem, which does not
correspond to
dynamic connectivity,
because it's this other problem,
prefix sums computation.
We get the intended lower bound,
you need log n per operation.
Or you need root n log
n per block operation.
OK, but this is not
what we really want,
we really want a lower
bound on verify sum.
Where you're given as an
argument the permutation that
we're talking about over here.
So this goal is not the
right goal for verify sum,
in some sense.
Well, sort of the right goal.
It's a little awkward
though, because they're
given as inputs to the queries.
So what is there to encode?
Well, we can still set
it up in a useful way.
Same goal, slightly restated.
So this is the last step
to verify sum lower bound.
So here's the set up.
OK, so slightly
different set up here.
Here I assumed that
we just knew the past.
I also basically assumed
these two things,
that we didn't know what
the update permutations were
in the left subtree,
and we didn't
know what the answers
to the queries
were in the right subtree.
Now I'm going to
assume we don't even
know what we're passing
into the queries,
because that is the information
we're trying to figure out.
These two things are
basically the same,
if you knew all the
update permutations,
you could figure out all
the query permutations.
If you knew all the
query permutations,
you could figure out all
the update permutations.
That's what we argued
over here, it's
enough to figure out
query permutations,
then we could figure out
the update permutations.
It's just a little more
awkward, because now there
are arguments to queries.
And so if we did this
simulation, right?
We'd simulate--
we don't know how
to simulate the query algorithm,
because it's supposed to be,
given the argument,
which is what
we're trying to figure out.
So we can't simulate
the query algorithm.
It's kind of annoying,
but otherwise
the set up is roughly the same.
The one thing we know
is that the query
is supposed to return
yes, because if you
look at this bad
access sequence,
it is designed to
always return yes.
So that is a thing we know,
but we don't know the arguments
to the updates on the left,
we don't know arguments
to the updates on the right.
We'll assume we know
everything else,
basically, up to this time.
Again, this is a
probabilistic statement,
that conditioned on the past,
conditioned on the queries
on the left, which
probably don't matter,
conditioned on the updates on
the right, which do matter,
but they're sort of irrelevant
to this r intersect w issue.
Conditioned on all
those things will
prove that the expected number
of operations you need to--
or expected encoding
size, for this problem,
is at least what it is,
l root n log n bits.
And from that lower
bound, you can then
take the sum over all possible
setups, over all conditions.
And that implies a lower
bound on the overall setting
without these assumptions.
OK?
So all I'm saying
is in this set up,
it still takes a lot of bits
to encode these updates,
because we don't have
the queries which
would tell us the answers.
So we get a lower bound
on encoding these updates,
or a lower bound on
encoding these queries,
because we assume
we don't know them.
The rest of the-- all
the remaining operations
don't tell us enough about this.
OK.
So how the heck are
we going to do--
prove a lower bound in
this setting, when we can't
simulate the query algorithm?
There's one cool idea
to make this work.
You may recall our last
cell probe lower bound
for the predecessor problem.
Use this idea of
round elimination.
The idea with round
elimination was--
Alice is sending a message,
Bob was sending a response.
But that first m--
we set things up,
we set up the problem so the
first message sent by Alice
had, on average, less than
1-bit of information to Bob,
or very little
information to Bob.
And so what Bob could
do is basically guess
what that message was.
And that would be accurate
with some probability.
Now here, we're
not quite allowed
to do that, we're
not allowed to change
the accuracy of our
results, because
of our particular setting.
So we can't afford to just
guess by flipping coins
what we were supposed to know.
What we're supposed
to know here is--
we're trying to simulate
a query operation,
and so we need to
know the argument,
that whole permutation
to the queries.
It's hard to run it
without that permutation.
So instead of guessing
by flipping coins,
we're going to guess in
the dynamic programming
sense, which is we're going
to try all the possibilities.
Run the simulation over
all possible queries,
all possible second
arguments to the query.
We don't know what the
presentation is, so
just try them all.
Cool thing is, only one
argument here should return yes.
That's the one
we're looking for.
So if you try them
all, find which
one says yes, we'll be done.
So this is called
the decoding idea.
Simulate verify sum of
i comma pi, for all pi.
And take the one that returns
yes, that is our permutation.
And so if we figure out what
those query permutations are,
then we figure out what the
update permutations are,
and we get our lower
bounds just like before.
OK.
This is easier said than
done, unfortunately.
We'd like to run the
simulation just like here, so
simulate inquiry algorithm.
They said, OK, still
the case, that if you're
reading a cell that's
either in the left subtree,
in the right subtree,
or in the past.
And we said this was
easy, this was known.
And the hard part is this
case, because if we're
running this query,
and it reads something
that was written in
the left subtree,
it may not be in r intersect w.
Why is that?
Little puzzle for you.
So we're running one of
these queries for sum pi.
And I claim that when we read
something in the left subtree,
we don't know if it's in r
intersect w, it might not be.
Let's see if we're
on the same page.
So r is the set of cells
read during the right subtree
when executing these operations.
OK?
But what we're doing now is
simulating some executions
that didn't necessarily happen.
We're doing a verify
sum of i comma pi,
but in the bad
access sequence, we
did verify sum of
i comma something
specific, not any pi,
but the correct pi.
So we only ran the
yes verify sums,
and that's what r is
defined with respect to.
r is the set of
things that get read
during these operations,
where the verify sum is always
output yes.
If you now run a verify
sum where the answer is no,
it may read stuff that the other
verify sum didn't read maybe.
Shouldn't matter,
but it's awkward,
because now it's not just r
intersect w we need to encode.
We need to encode
some more stuff.
It's basically a
new r prime that
may happen during these
reads, and we just
can't afford to
encode that r prime,
because it's not the
thing we care about.
We care about what happens in
the actual access sequence,
not in this
arbitrary simulation.
So this is the annoying thing.
Trouble.
If you look at an incorrect
query, meaning the wrong pi,
this is like a no
query, the output's no.
Reads some different
set of cells, r
prime, which isn't
the same thing as r.
And so if-- we have
some good news, which
is if we can somehow
detect that this happened,
that we read something that
is in r prime, but not r,
then the answer must be no.
So that's our saving
hope, is that either we're
reading something at r
intersect w, in which case
it's been written down,
we know how to do it.
What's not written there, and
if it's not written there,
then it should be, hopefully,
in r prime minus r.
So the answer should be no.
Maybe.
Slight problem,
though, because we
used r intersect w to
detect what case we were in.
If we were in r
intersect w, then
we knew we should read
from those encoded cells.
If we weren't, we were either
in the past or in the right
subtree, these things
were easy to detect,
because they got written
during the simulation.
But we need to
distinguish between--
did we read something that
was in the left subtree,
or did we read something
that was known?
This is a little tricky, because
this gets at exactly the issue.
Left subtree might
write some stuff that
didn't get read by verify sum.
So now you go to read
it, you need to know,
am I reading something that
was not in r intersect w?
And therefore-- Yeah.
Basically the issue
is, is it in w?
If it's in w, but
not in r intersect w,
then I know the answer
is no, and I should stop.
If it's not in w though, that
means it was in the known past,
and then I should continue.
How do I know if I
should stop or continue?
So this is the tricky part.
We can't tell whether
there's the weird notation.
We want to know whether r is
in w minus r or past minus r
intersect w.
OK, we can tell whether
it's in r intersect w,
if it is, we're happy.
If it's not in r
intersect w, it could
be that's because it was
just in some past thing we
were reading, that didn't
get read otherwise.
Or it could be we're
reading something
that was written in
the left subtree,
but not read in
the right subtree.
So in this case,
we want to abort.
And in this case, it's known,
and so we just continue.
So that's what the
simulation would like to do,
if we could distinguish
between these two cases.
But right now, we can't
distinguish between these two
cases, because we don't
have enough information.
So we're going to make our
encoding a little bit bigger.
What we're going to do--
this is here-- is
encode a separator
for r minus w and w minus r.
So let's-- over here.
What does this mean?
Separators going to call, called
S. So I want this picture,
r minus w sits inside
S. And w minus r
sits outside S. This is
my universe of cells.
These are the things that are
read in the right subtree,
but not written in
the left subtree.
Those are the things
I care about--
well, no quite this,
the other ones.
So things that are read in
the right subtree and that
are not written in the last,
this is the past essentially,
that's useful over there.
Over here, I have
w minus r, these
are things that are written
in the left subtree,
but not read in
the right subtree.
These are the things
that I worry about,
because those ones I need to
detect that that was changed,
and say whoops, you must
have an answer of no.
OK?
So I can't afford to
store these sets exactly,
so I'm going to approximate
them, by saying,
well, let's store the
separator out here.
And if you're in S, then you're
definitely not in w minus r.
If you're definitely not in
w minus r, then you can run--
you can treat it
as if it was known.
OK, so if you're in
s, this would be--
why don't I write it here.
For the decoding
algorithm, if you
want to read a cell
that is written,
or last written in the
right subtree, in the past,
these are the two easy case.
Sorry-- I don't want to
write what's in the past,
because the whole point is to
figure out what's in the past.
The other easy case is
if it's in r intersect w,
then it's written down for us.
So this is encoded.
This is easy, because during the
simulation we did those rights,
and so we know what they were.
r intersect w, we've written
down, so it's easy to know.
Then the other cases
are either you're in S,
or you're not in S. OK.
I claim if you're in S,
you must be in the past,
that cell must have been
written in the past,
and so you know
what the value was.
And so you can continue
writing the simulation,
just like in this situation.
The other situation is you're
not in S, then you don't know,
it could have been written
or might not have been.
But what you know is that
you're definitely not in r.
Because if you're
not in r minus w,
and you're not in r intersect
w, then you're not in r.
If you're not in r, then
we're in this situation.
If you read something
not in r, that means
you're running the wrong query.
Because the correct
query does r--
only reads from r.
So if you're not an S,
you must not be in r.
And so in this case, you
know you can abort and try
the next pi.
So we're going to do
this for all pi, run
the simulation according to
this way of reading cells.
At the end, the queries are
either going to say yes or no,
or it may abort early.
So if it says no
or it aborts early,
then we know that
was not the right pi.
Only one of them can say yes,
that tells us what the pi is,
that tells us what
the queries were.
Once we know what the queries
were in the right subtree,
we can use the same
multiplying by inverses trick,
figure out what the updates
were in the left subtree.
But those permutations
require l root n log n bits.
Which used to be on this
board, it's been erased now.
That's what we use
for this argument.
And so what we get
is overall, encoding
must use l root n log n bits.
OK, but our encoding's
a little bit bigger now.
The big issue is how do
we store the separator?
We need to do store this
separator with very few bits,
otherwise we haven't
really proved anything.
We want encoding to be small.
So we get that the
encoding must use
omega l root n log n bits
in expectation, because this
is a valid decoding
algorithm, it will figure out
what the permutations were.
And they require at
least this many bits,
so encoding must use this
many bits in expectation.
Now the question is how many
bits does the encoding use?
Then we'll get either
a contradiction
or we'll prove the claim.
So let's go over here.
So here's a fun fact
about separators.
I'm not going to prove
it fully, but I'm
going to rely on
some hashing ability.
So given some universe
U, in this case
it's going to be the cells
in our data structure.
But speak a little bit more
generally of the universe U,
I have some number m,
which is our set size.
And what we're interested in
is in defining our separator
family.
Kind of like a family of hash
functions, closely related,
in fact.
Call it S. And it's going
to work for size m sets.
And so S is a separator family
if, for any two sets, A and B,
in the universe of size,
at most, m, and disjoint.
So A intersect B
is the empty set.
So of course what we're thinking
about here is r minus w,
and w minus r.
These are two subsets
of the universe.
Hopefully they're not too big,
because if this one is huge,
that means you read
a huge amount of data
in the right subtree.
If this one is huge, it meant
you wrote a huge amount of data
in the left subtree.
And then we get lower
bounds in an easier way.
Or they're not so big, let's
say they're size at most m.
They're disjoint for sure,
by definition, r minus w's
disjoint from w minus r.
It removes the intersection.
So that's our set up.
Then, what we
want, is that there
is some set C in the
separator family,
such that A is contained in
C, and B is outside of C.
So B is in the universe minus C.
So this is exactly our picture
from before, we have
A. A contains C,
and we have B over on the right.
And this is the whole universe
U, and so B is outside of C,
A is entirely inside C. OK.
This is what we want to
exist, because if a separator
family exists, then we know
whatever our r minus w, and w
minus r sets were, as long
as they're not too big,
they're definitely
disjoint, we can
find one of these separators
that encodes what we need
to encode, which is the set C.
Which is called s over there.
Cool.
How do we encode it?
Well, if the number--
if the size of the separator
family is something,
then we need log of that bits
to write down the separator set.
So as long as this is
small, we're happy.
So let me tell you what's
to know about separators
There exists a separator family
S, with size of S at most 2
to the order m
plus log log U. Now
this is getting into
an area that we haven't
spent a lot of time on, but--
so I'm going to
give you a sketch
of a proof of this claim.
Relying on perfect
hash functions.
So the idea is the following,
we want to know, basically,
which elements are in A,
which elements are in B.
But it's kind of annoying
to do that, it can't start
that for all universe elements.
So if we could just find a
nice perfect hash function that
maps the elements of a
and the elements would
B to different slots
in some hash table,
then for every slot in the hash
table we could say, is it in A,
or is it in B?
Now if you are not in A union
B and you hash somewhere,
you'll get some bit, who
knows what that that stores.
I don't care.
For the things
outside of A union B,
they could be in C or not
in C, I don't really care.
And so all I care about
is if A and B have
no collisions
between each other,
I don't want any A thing
to hash to B thing.
Then I can store a bit in
every cell in the hash table,
and that will tell me, in
particular, A versus B.
And then the rest of the
items are somehow categorized,
but I don't care how
they're categorized.
So we're going to use
this fact that there
is a set of perfect hash
functions of the same size.
Sorry, that should be H. This
is what's really true, size of H
is 2 the order m
plus log log U. OK,
I'm not going to prove
this, but this is
about succinct hash functions.
It may be hard to find
such a hash family,
but the claim is
that they exist.
Or it's hard to find the hash
function of the family that
has no collisions,
but the guarantee
is, as long as you have,
in total, two items,
out of your universe
of size U, you
can get a collision-free
hash function,
2 to the order m plus log log U.
OK.
So this is going to--
Yeah.
Maps, say A union B, to
an order m sized table.
And here, there
are no collisions.
So then what we also
store is an A or B
bit for each table entry.
So that's our encoding.
We store a perfect
hash function, that's
going to cost log H bits
for this part, and log of H
is just m plus log
log U. And then
we're going to store this A or
B bit for every table entry.
Number of table
entries is order m,
so this is going to take
2 to the order m bits.
Or sorry, not-- sorry, in term
of bits, its order m bits,
I should say.
In terms of functions,
it's 2 to the order m
possible choices
for this bit vector.
And so the easy way is to
just sum up these bits,
you use log of H bits
plus order m bits.
This already had an order m
term, and so you get this.
The log of S is order
m plus log log U.
So that's the end of
proof sketch of the claim.
If you believe perfect hash
functions can be written down
in a small way, then we're done.
Now first with separators,
now let's apply this separator
theorem claim to this setting.
So now we can compute
the size of our encoding,
our encoding involved
writing down r intersect w.
That takes r intersect w
times log n, just like before.
It also involves writing
down the separator.
Separator takes order
m bits, m is r plus w.
Things that are--
it's order r plus w.
These are all the things--
I'm trying to write
down r minus w and w
minus r, so that you add
up those sizes, basically r
plus w.
Plus log log U. U
is some small thing,
size of memory, number
of cells in memory.
We're assuming that
polynomials, so you
take log log of a polynomial,
that's like log log n.
So let's finish this off.
So before this was our
equation, r intersect w times
log n, that was the
size of our encoding.
We still have that term.
Sorry, r intersect w,
size of that, times log n.
So we still do that.
Now we also pay,
for this separator,
we're going to pay r plus
w, that's the m part.
Plus log log n.
This is the number of
bits in our encoding.
And I claim, or what
we've proved over here,
is that any encoding must
use l root n log n bits.
So this thing must be
at least this thing.
So we have a little
bit more work to prove.
There are now two cases.
It depends-- there's basically--
and log log n is
unlikely to dominate.
We're doing a block
operation on root n things,
probably need to use at
least log log n steps.
So it's not really relevant.
What will dominate is either
this term, as it used to,
or this term.
These are two different cases,
call them case one, case two.
In case two, r plus w is
at least l root n log n.
That's the lower bound we want.
If we can-- in case two, r
plus w is omega l root n log n.
What that means is in this
subtree, the amount of reading
we did in the right
subtree, plus the amount
of writing we did
in the left subtree,
is at least l root n log n.
That's our goal over here.
We want to prove--
sorry, it's a previous
claim, that's by now erased.
Is the easier
claim, we just want
to show that the total amount
of time spent in v's subtree
is at least log n per operation.
We're doing l root
n things here.
So this is a ton of
reading and writing.
So in that case, we're
happy, because we get
an actual lower bound on time.
Otherwise, we don't-- I
mean, these are actual reads
and writes, or total
number of reads and writes.
Here we're getting--
in the other case,
we get r intersect w log
n is at least l root n log
n, just like before.
So again, the log ns cancel.
So here we lose
the log n factor,
but it's OK,
because this is only
talking about r intersect w.
This we use the LCA
charging, to say, well,
if you look at a
particular read,
it's only gets
charged by the LCA.
So then we can afford
to sum up large amounts.
So it's a little bit weird.
In this situation, we add
up all the lower bounds.
Each of them doesn't
give us a log n,
but in aggregate, we get a log
n, because every leaf appears
in log n levels.
In this case, we don't need to
aggregate, because we just say,
well, the number of
operations in the subtree
is at least log n per operation.
This time spent,
cell probe's done,
is at least log n per operation.
So in that case, we don't need
to sum the lower bounds, which
is done.
So in either case, we're happy.
Little weird, because you
could have a mix of cases,
one vertex v could
be in case two,
then you just ignore
all the things below it.
The rest of the tree
might be in case one,
but you can mix and
match one and two,
as long as you don't use a
one below a two, you're OK,
you won't double count.
And so in either
case, we're happy,
we get a log n lower bound,
either on time per operation,
or on this kind of
time per operation.
Add up all those lower bounds,
you get log n per operation,
or get root n log n per
block operation, which
implies log n per insert delete
edge, or connectivity query.
And that proves right
there, more or less on time.
You can use the same
technique to do a trade off
between updates and queries.
This is just log n,
worst case of the two.
I mentioned what the
bound was last time.
Same trick works, you
just do more updates
than queries, or more
queries than updates.
So we get link/cut
trees are optimal, other
[? tour ?] trees are optimal.
And we've got lots of
other points on the trade
off curve, as you may
recall last class.
Like our log squared update is
optimal for a log over log log
query.
And that's the end of
dynamic graphs, the end
of advanced data structures.
Hope you had a fun
time, we got to see
lots of different topics.
And I hope you'll enjoy
watching on the videos,
and let me know if you have
any comments, send an email
or whatever.
Yay.
[APPLAUSE]